ils sont bloqués au port de saint
florentin depuis un mois anne et son
mari viennent de grande-bretagne à cause
du manque d'eau impossible pour eux de
naviguer plus loin sur le canal de
bourgogne une longue escale imposés
qu'ils prennent avec beaucoup de
philosophie
nous sommes en retraite alors cep sait
moins c'est moins compliqué si vous
voulez oui oui ça peut être en béton
mais ne sont pas énervés
avec la sécheresse la rivière armançon
ne peut plus alimenter le canal de
bourgogne conséquences
interdiction pour les péniches de
naviguer mais son péniche pas de
rentrées financières pour les ports
celui de saint florentin accuse déjà une
perte de 20 mille euros à saint
florentin en année normale on a 500
bateaux de passage alors d'aujourd'hui
on n'a que 50 10 % la sécheresse est
responsable oui il n'ya pas que ça le
manque d'entretien du canal et la
gestion d'eau de la part de vnf n'est
pas n'est pas au niveau des conséquences
aussi pour les commerces locaux
déjà fragilisé par le confinement la
communauté de communes a récemment
investi dans cet hôtel restaurant pour
le rénover et l'absence des plaisanciers
se fait ressentir
nos commerçants sont les premiers
impactés et ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai du mal à tolérer et notamment le
voyez ici l'hôtel de la sq et qu'il y
allait rouvrir et bien est aussi
impactée ça il fait perdre en gros on
estime à entre 5 et 10% de son chiffre
d'affaires sur le mois d'août est le
mois de septembre un nouvel été gâchée
pour le port de saint florentin la
navigation entre migennes et tonnerre ne
devrait pas reprendre avant l'année
prochaine